Google cloud next 2017 featured a rich
variety of talks detailing the future of
cloud if you didn't get a chance to
catch the location powered on-demand
economy then stay tuned because here's
the recap powered by smartphones and the
ability to determine location the
on-demand economy reflects a significant
shift in user behaviors and expectations
as a result we've seen significant
disruptions in many traditional
businesses for example we used to hail a
taxi on the street now we can request a
car from an app on our phones or
consider that eating restaurant food at
home with limits to takeout or pizza
delivery today we can get anything from
fresh ingredients to move from just
about any restaurant delivered within
the hour it's important to note that
these new business models are driven by
location power technology customers
requests cars or place an order on their
apps that indicate their current
location meanwhile the fleet of drivers
and delivery people fulfilling those
requests are constantly using location
powered apps to figure out how to get to
their customers for example traditional
taxi and delivery drivers had to
memorize routes and locations to
efficiently navigate their cities
without digital assistants but with
real-time navigation and routing
technology this need for specialized
knowledge is removed enabling businesses
to significantly increase their fleet of
drivers with less training cost now you
can include those same features within
your own apps using the Google Maps API
switch are available on android iOS web
and HTTP based services these api's give
you the power to do everything from
visualizing points on a map to routing
and planning for deliveries to pre
programming television remotes based on
their physical location in order to
understand how to take best advantage of
these features let's focus on user
habits and expectations constant
technology advancements have led to the
user expectations of continuous
improvement in speed and convenience we
expect our webpages to load faster and
movies to be high resolution our
deliveries to arrive within minutes and
our phones to not only tell us how to
reach your destination but also to
navigate around accidents or bad traffic
in terms of services that translates
into expectations for continually
improving simplicity and predictability
sadly one caveat with this economic
and is that while user expectations for
simple and convenient services was on
the rise willingness to pay for them is
on the decline for example cheap fixed
price physical deliveries soon became
unlimited free delivery and low prices
for digital goods quickly evolved into
unlimited plans for music video and
mobile data with service expectations
increasing and consumer willingness to
pay decreasing the challenge for
companies is to find ways to deliver
efficiencies of scale that will enable
the margins they need to thrive the
issue with location-based systems is no
longer the logistics in managing a fleet
deploying it or even getting to the last
mile instead the challenge has shifted
to the last tenth of a mile for example
it's not enough to just go to an address
you now have to find a specific person
standing on the corner of that address
the result is the new location based
economy isn't really about location it's
about places the concept of a place is
important to consumers on the move
people want to know that before they
head out to a restaurant is it going to
be busy is it open right now or is it
even worth going to while the previous
location-based data changes slowly
months at a time this new location
economy is filled with information
that's dynamic affected by the time of
day traffic local events and even
changes in a business location keeping
up with all of these changes yourself
globally is really hard which is where
Google can help the Google Maps team is
committed to finding creative solutions
to help developers like you find
efficiencies in the last tenth of a mile
the result is that our mapping API is
returned up-to-the-minute data that
reflects the dynamic nature of the
location powered economy check out the
full recording of this session to see
more examples of location the on-demand
economy and what the future holds and of
course if you want more recaps on great
next content make sure to check out the
rest of our playlist and don't forget
the next world tour coming soon to a
city near you
you